one of the greatest joys of being an
adult is getting a brand new washing
machine oh and it does drying too it's
still wet it's still wet but that's okay
because I can dry it for longer my brand
new washer/dryer whoo
live the adventure I have friends who
sometimes do this thing where they will
couple together a bunch of footage from
the month and cool it their pretentious
monthly scrapbook in my case I think the
pretentious is probably pretty heavily
implied so here's my monthly scrapbook
but one cool thing I did do last month
was I went to Berlin oh so in
preparation for that I did try and
relearn some German ich Kenne in I I'm
not good at this one I used to take it
back in school I got an a GCSE I
couldn't really remember much though see
mug ei de Zeitung she likes every
newspaper easy to please do you me do
you like me yeah do you like me
Mook here he got practice that spoiler
illa in the end I think I said one
German word while I was there
insured gong which i think is a formal
sorry but my worried about whether or
not that was actually correct was enough
to make me not say any more German while
I was there at all and then William and
Charlie brothers from the same mother
went on the brotherly adventure that
would change their lives a little Berlin
Wow Wow
you see he looks amazing from up here
and of peace
like you've never seen it before
Oh
right now
it's the thing but then
what is it
the president okay
but inspector through your camera than
in real life in your garage
I'll just stand here behind you look
through the screen that's the way to do
it don't experience anything like I'm
just there all in all the holiday in
Berlin was absolutely lovely really like
bonding with my brother having to spend
a kind of good chunk of time like that
with him in quite a while so that was
awesome there was one thing that
happened in Berlin though that I didn't
end up getting any footage from probably
for the best my brother really wanted to
go clubbing in Berlin because he's a
normal person and I didn't but I also
know that sometimes doing a thing you
don't want to do can lead to a good
experience because that's life we tried
to go to the Berg Hein which is a
notoriously difficult Club to get into
once we found the line we were in it for
about two hours eventually once we got
to the end of the line we realized we
were queuing for the wrong Club it was a
club that was in the same building as
the Berg kind so easy mistake to make I
think if you're not really familiar with
how the thing works but it turned out
that the club we'd been queuing for for
two hours was the most notorious sex
fetish club in the entire world I mean
each to their own whatever you enjoy if
it's legal and consenting which I know
it is at that place then groovy dovey
boat but we booba do be do what you want
to do but it's not my thing I'm just
very pleased that they didn't let us in
over to whoopsie daisies whoopsie
daisies I'd say about a third of my
September was spent working on my other
YouTube channel see real time and boy oh
boy don't we just get up to some crazy
high jinks right is that
you my very special creamy yes you happy
stay is so creepy don't touch me with it
I'll touch myself then it's awesome oh
dear it's behind the scenes on cereal
time
oh yeah behind its own go that's all
secret desk right there yeah normally
you only you only get to see it bit look
at that
Oh slow zoom alright dramatic tender
heart be over there - I normally see
that do you see that there's something
in there Josh wanna fix his computer
yeah frame ax head yeah obviously it's a
secret it's like another character on
the show
it's nipple balloon everyone photo photo
oh poor little eating pleasure out of
this okay
if it was wet that would be the worst
thing in the world forgive me I did Oh
God probably my favorite thing that
happened in September regarding cereal
time was when my how do I explain this
we do a thing on the show where we
pretend that we would maybe we decide
about we pretend that we might date pets
I don't know there are animals and we we
might date them if we were the animals
cereal types so weird we filmed the
thing where we pretended that Jimmy was
going on a date with my cat Gideon don't
ask Kara some outtakes
oh wow that looks great
so fish isn't it so cold and fishy and
dry so how do you think it went Jimmy I
went so well he's so funny
what do you think people will have to
say about this potential relationship I
mean there'll be a few September was
also my last month of being a 24 year
old man I am now 25 can you tell I've
got a new age what do you think how does
it suit me I feel a bit different I
guess I feel a little more crewed up
obviously I mean it in the sense that I
feel I feel more adult I feel more like
responsible but those are more connected
to just the month in general that stuff
that happened did it not necessarily
because I got older it's the final day
of September so time for some
reflections just got done filming cereal
time all day everyone's gone now that's
why I'm here what can I say about
September there was a lot of good stuff
and there was also some not good stuff
at all I already know yet if I want to
talk about like the not good stuff in my
life because I don't know because you
know you never know if you want to make
these things happy or sad you want to
show the whole story
sometimes worried that with me the whole
story can just get a bit so I don't know
what do you what do you think would you
prefer to see some of the not good stuff
in my life would you prefer me to be
sharing that with you or do you just
want to see happy fun charlie because I
can do both and they're both like
important big parts of my life and who
of who I am and I guess I'm never gonna
be able to show the whole of me because
that's too scary these are my final
hours of being 24 mm
I'm from hi we have so much whipped
cream look at it look at the cream
heated cream they're so good
I would eat a pie of just whipped cream
very impressed by this
good job puppet trigger today's video
blog was written and directed by Gideon
my cat who has been here the whole time
just you know keeping an eye on things
he's staying with me Gideon I am gonna
be such an embarrassing dad aren't I
goodbye even that was embarrassing to
say it you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
thank you very much for watching if
you'd like to see my previous video that
I made 14 years ago that's over there
and friendly reminder if you miss me if
you've been missing me recently a good
thing to do is to watch cereal time
because that is every single weekday
morning I could be in your life like way
more than if you are only watching this
channel so just to just a thought but if
you don't like it that's cool too I
don't mind and that's the end spy